من جانبها قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه نتالياه
ادى الى غمر حقول الالغام وجميع التحصينات
التي اقامتها القوات الروسيه عند الخطوط
الاماميه للضفه اليسرى من نهر في خرسون
واكدت ان القوات الروسيه تراجعت ما بين
خمسه كيلومترات وخمسه عشر كيلومترا في
الضفه اليسرى من النهر ما ادى الى تراجع
حده القصف على الضفه اليمنى
اغرق العدو خطوطه الدفاعيه الاولى وغمرت
المياه كافه التحصينات وحقول الالغام التي
اقامتها القوات الروسيه في الضفه اليسرى
اجبرت المياه قوات العدو على التراجعي في
مناطق مختلفه من خمسه الى 15 كيلو مترا ما
ادى الى تراجع حده القصف على الضفه اليمنى
لانهم مشغولون الان باعاده الانتشار بعد
انحسار المياه لن تستطيع القوات الروسيه
استخدام تلك المواقع المغموره كمواقع
دفاعيه
ماشي